[Music]
the question came up of whether you
could hear earthquakes and and I said I
don't think so but we could take the
data and speed it up and listen to the
whole planet ring after in this place
[Music]
the size modem show is a ongoing project
in which we use earthquakes and the
waves that they emit to teach people
about the planet all right now we're
going to go to the Tohoku earthquake
so in the show we have a magnitude 7 you
know and that energy dies out in about a
day whereas a magnitude 9 or higher the
earth is ringing for about three months
with every passage of a seismic wave
through the earth we get a little more
information about the structure of the
inside
[Music]
we're always playing with time so we'll
always say this is seven years of
earthquakes you're going to hear it in a
minute that means just the list of
earthquakes where they were and how big
they were and how deep they were we want
to give people a sense of how small we
are how short our lifetimes are and
hopefully they walk out of that
planetarium with a very altered sense of
their lives and our
on earth
[Music]